est-ce vraiment surprenant que l'
homme le plus puissant du monde soit une
figure de controverse nous, en tant que population
sur cette planète, cherchions un
sauveur nous parlons d'un
milliard dont vous ne nous dites pas
la vérité défie  notre propre sens de la
priorité dans l'univers les êtres humains
ont un bilan horrible de la France qui
suit des gens avec un grand pouvoir
corrompt et le pouvoir absolu corrompt
absolument le chaos peut-être qu'il est juste un gars qui
essaie de faire le bon petit mieux
maintenant, non Dieu les démons ne le font pas  venir d'aider
soit a écrit leur guerrier ils viennent
du ciel le monde a été tellement
rattrapé par ce qu'il peut faire que
personne n'a demandé ce qu'il devait
faire c'est comme ça que ça déclenche la fièvre la rage
le sentiment d'impuissance qui rend les
hommes bons
cruels
dire  moi tu plaides
tu veux
tu